To boom. George Lockhart.
John Cavenaugh. How I folks. Hello
Sir. Good to see you. Good to be here.
Um,
so Saturday night,
what are your thoughts now that we're
sitting here? It's Monday morning. The,
the could be McGregor fight went down
Saturday night and obviously hugely
disappointed. I didn't get the results
from the night. I still enjoyed it.
I tell it was a great fight.
I'm looking forward to watching the back
of many times. All the corners fights.
I always pull a over the lessons away
that I can pass on to the next generation
of guys.
But yeah,
overall I really enjoyed the fight and
I'm devastated that we didn't get there.
Yeah. How much time did he have
to prepare for this fight? Um,
I mean he's always in the gym. He's
always, he's always knocking about,
but I guess it was official over 10 weeks,
10 weeks out.
But even since the 85 I kind of knew,
or at least I taught his next MMA fight,
would be happy with,
just just kind of made sense if
it wasn't going to be the Diaz,
but then as time went on that
that seemed less and less likely.
And Habib obviously he was doing
great, you know, kept on winning.
So there was a path that
was going to collide.
Was there anything that was
surprising in the fight? Um,
the, the, the right hand and
the second round was, yeah,
it was a cracker was beautiful.
Overhung right. I mean it's a,
it's a staple of wrestlers,
overhand right. And clothes,
but he doesn't generally do
it's more job and then close.
But that was a great chart and this style
of takedowns everything was planned of
what we expected. And we spent a lot
of time in preparing for that. Um,
yeah, just I, I, you know,
kind of expected round warm for sure.
Going to get a take down.
So the goal of round wound was to get
out of it. It's still having energy.
We do month to put a huge amount of effort
into trying to get back open rear one
we've seen that happen many times in his
or her opponents and to kind of go back
to the stool, you know, really tired
so [inaudible] make him pay, you know,
do our best on the way in fight as hard
as we can. But if you do end up down it,
which it was against the fence,
figured it would be there,
tried to stay seated up. If we end up in
our back, just tried to play guard until,
until it, until the Bell, except
it will be a ten nine round
for round two. Again, same,
same plan and do as much damage as we can.
But if we end up on our back,
I don't put a huge amount of
effort and trying to get up.
He's an absolute master,
a regrounding people and that turned
out to be a ten eight round. You know,
he got some good shots there and obviously
he landed the greater right hand.
So that was a bit more than we hoped for
around treating things started kind of
turning a little bit in our favor and
we did a lot better at keeping it in the
middle, defending the takedowns until
the plan was to slow him down a little.
I would watch him slow down a little bit
in the third, fourth and fifth. Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So I think I at the beginning that the
consensus was Conan x amount in the first
or her be, you know, takes over
from to on like first the wind,
the third round was probably a bit of
a surprise to people but and you know,
he knowed eloquent,
acquaint the fight if you look at that
for Montreal and he wasn't able to hit
any take downs. Um, so
hoped that's what we have.
We'll go around tree,
we could defend the takedowns a lot
easier and start landing air shots and,
and that did happen for round tree,
not as well as I as we
plan as well as we hoped.
And then a around for, you know,
we hit another great takedown,
made it mistake given up the over hook,
exposed our back.
And that was all she wrote.
Yeah.
He has such a unique ability to tie
both legs up with his legs. Yeah.
So I'm calling around one,
I thought college as well.
We would practice for that,
for, to keep her legs bent.
You know, you see guys,
he straightened her legs and then from,
and Connor did do that a couple of times,
but he was able to
continue to get a leg free.
So not until the last 30
seconds or so around one.
He didn't really tie
them up and get him flat,
flatten his back for the majority of
that, he was against the fence, you know,
use his hands to keep upright,
tried to learn a little shots. Um,
yeah.